cool stealth is key for these Frontline
drone operators
training in the forests of central
Ukraine
skillful use of a fast evolving
technology that is redefining strategy
and operations on the Eastern and
Southern battlefields
but its civilians not soldiers training
these Ukrainian Special Forces
five thousand servicemen have passed
through this drone training camp since
Russia's Invasion 14 months ago
they learn drone reconnaissance
artillery guidance weapons delivery and
systems jamming
the alarm you can hear there means that
a drone has been detected and there's
devices like these as you can imagine
being used right the way across the
front line
and kit like this can detect drones up
to 30 kilometers away
drones have changed tactics each War has
its own characteristic during the second
world war advanced technology was tanks
now it's drones and artillery
civilian drone enthusiasts are
contributing more and more to Ukraine's
war effort
most are self-funded and only make
enough money to cover their costs
drones were my hobby for eight years but
when The Invasion happened I realized I
could be useful we have to get our men
out of the trenches and fight more with
machines
as another underground Workshop 3D
printers make Parts including grenade
clips and Bomb release systems
batteries are made from disused Vapes
we constantly get specific requests from
the guys on the front line we are
inventing producing assembling things
that will help them
[Music]
Russia has been using iranian-made
so-called Kamikaze drones whilst Ukraine
uses us-made drones such as the
switchblade that explodes on impact but
training and Innovative production by
civilians developing systems like these
aims at supplying Soldiers with cheap
weapons they say Ukraine's Western
allies cannot provide Charles Strafford
Al Jazeera Kiev